I ran for president as you know, uh,
and there was a time when it felt like there are game mechanics at play during
the campaign there. Uh,
when I called it out as a reality TV show at one point on the debates,
but then I was still participating in the reality TV show. And for me,
it hit home when I did something that was totally random where I was in South
Carolina. And there were,
there was a Jazzercise class and there were women doing the Cupid shuffle,
and then not wanting to be rude. I was like, okay, like,
let me do it with you and just have some fun. Um,
and I literally forgot that we had like a journalist in tow, um,
at the time who just took the video on their phone and then it
wound up. And then to me,
the shockingly people gave a about me doing the Cupid shuffle,
such that it went around the, uh, social media landscape.
And then it went to mainstream news where I was part of like a,
I did a Sunday morning network TV appearance,
and they use that as like my intro clip. Um, whereas like here's Andrew. Yeah.
He's having fun on the trail. And I was like, what the hell is going on?
Where were literally running?
I got this whole big set of ideas that obviously like, you know, I,
I think vitally important for our nation's future. And it's like,
but that doesn't matter. You don't matter. It's like you keep it shuffling, uh,
in South Carolina.
Yeah. And I, I mean, I think that there's,
I think there's like some legitimacy to this and you've talked about it a little
bit on the podcast before that, you know, people believe stories and like,
we want to find stories that we fit into and we want to find stories that other
people fit into. And so if, you know, that's kind of a lot of what politics is,
is like trying to tell a story around your opponent and tell a story around
yourself and make those the most compelling stories and more compelling than
their stories, because, and like, this is a shame to some extent,
but, but also, you know,
this is a democracy and most people do not have anything like the
amount of time that you and I have to think about this stuff.
And so we need simplifying stories.
We need ways for people to be engaged and informed and to, and to,
you know, without having to spend 40 hours a week on it. And,
uh, and so like, you know, to some extent it's like, this is,
this is terrible and, and very concerning. And to some extent,
like those things do have to exist.
We just have to be as citizens really aware of how stories function
and, and wary of, uh, how,
how they're going to be used to manipulate us.
So if we look at the social media platforms, we say, okay,
there are serious problems with them.
And I have a few policy proposals that I put out on the trail
and we launched the data dividend project,
which I just had this long meeting about.
And here's where gets interesting is where, uh,
this is the story we're trying to tell to your point is like story one.
When you say to the average American, Hey,
your data is yours and you should have data dignity.
It's about like human autonomy and free will.
And then an American will hear that and be like, yeah, yeah, I agree with that.
Um, but then they, but they won't really do anything. I mean,
it's like just click on, I consent, uh, you know,
use these platforms and just ignore and hope for the best. Cause like you said,
I don't have any time I'm busy.
Yep. Oh yeah. I'd rather trade my, my convenience for my privacy any day,
I'll take that deal.
So that was a story one and a number of people have tried that story and it
has not gone anywhere. And then we'd looked at it and said, okay,
you know what our story is going to be.
They are making tens of billions of dollars a year off of you and your data.
Shouldn't you get some of that.
Why don't we just get you this data dividend sign up here and we'll go fight for
your right to get paid for your data.
And so I'm very excited about that. Cause I think that's a winning story. And,
uh, we we've now had, um, tens of thousands of people sign up, um, in,
in the first week and we were fighting on that side.
And then there were some people that came back and said, Hey,
that isn't the policy goal. You should have, uh,
people getting paid for their data because they're not going to get paid enough.
And it, you know,
it's still going to continue some of like the darker issues that I think you
driving at, um, in your book. And I looked at it, I, you know,
looked at it and was like,
so you don't want us to try and get people paid for their data because you
think there's like a better policy that frankly I wouldn't even necessarily
disagree with.
Like if you gave me the power to pass like a better data rights policy that made
it. So these practices were off the table, like I would be thrilled.
I would sign that. But you know, like right now that's not feasible.
Like Congress is not going to take that up. So in the meantime,
let's like try and activate people around this. Um,
so I hear what you're saying that like a lot of what we're
engaged with is different appeals, different stories, different storylines,
uh, thinking that somehow we're going to be communicating purely on a rational
basis, uh, is silly, I suppose.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I think that,
I think that there's a story to tell around rationality, for sure.
And I think that that will resonate with some people and not with others.
And that's what happened with my campaign, Hank,
where like I started out communicating very rationally and I think it attracted
a particular tribe people now that tribe was less than
51%. So then we were looking around being like, okay,
like how can we try and get someone else to join this tribe?
We've got all the people we're going to get with this strategy.
So let's expand to the strategy. Yeah.
Yeah. So, so that was one of the things that I was engaged with. Uh, but, uh,
to push a little bit further.
So if you were in the room with,
let's say members of Congress or the president or something, and they were just,
and I'm going to play act, um, as Joe Biden, let's say maybe I'll,
I'll pretend to be Joe. Sure. Why not? Um, it'll be.
Easier than the alternative. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I think it's going to be, Joe is people know. So,
uh, so Joe looks at you and says, Hank, uh, congratulations. My, um,
grandchildren are fans of yours. Uh,
what should we do about these social media platforms, uh,
to improve things for the next generation? Well.
I mean, this is,
so the first thing I think is that there are antitrust concerns here.
I don't think that YouTube and Google should be the same company.
I don't know that Google and Android should be the same company.
I don't think that AWS and Amazon should be the same company like that to
me, feels like there's just too much consolidated power there.
And it's interesting because like I know some of the people high up at YouTube
fairly well. I think that they're really good people.
And I think that they believe that what they are doing is the right thing for
the world.
But what I don't believe is that any unelected leader should have as
much power as they have. And, and,
and it's not power over the government, it's power over our lives.
And w and so I think that we need to make space for there to be
competition here. And if there are,
if there is a great D if there are these moats that are created by these
companies, like, and maybe the, the, the anti-trust, isn't just breaking up,
or maybe it's, it's something other than breaking up where, you know,
you prevent companies from buying competitors,
which used to be a thing like this used to be rules around this. You,
you can't have them buy competitors to put them out of business. Um,
or, and you also just, can't like,
just sort of like gobble up the people who are going to take your market share,
because like, we need more than one and we need more than 10,
ideally different companies in this so that they can innovate different ways.
They can create platforms that are going to appeal to different types of people
there, and like create, um, you know,
tools that they wouldn't have thought of.
And that are going to be better for folks. Now,
obviously there are network effects when it comes to this stuff.
Like I upload stuff to YouTube,
not because I think it's the best video platform,
but because that's where the eyeballs are. And I,
I'm never going to change that until the eyeballs are somewhere else,
but I think that there are ways to open that up and, um, and,
and create. And so I, I think that's, that's the first thing is to say,
how do we like recreate a competitive landscape here?
And whether that's breaking them up, like we did with, uh, the,
the bells or whether it's, um, you know, creating some kind of,
uh, forces against monopoly, because right now,
like it's great for their stock. Like, but like,
there's no doubt in anyone's mind that these companies are building really big
moats and that they're getting, you know, and they're, they're building moats,
not just around sort of customer interactions, but in,
in some cases what I'm starting to imagine as more citizenship interactions
where we don't these aren't, these aren't companies, we buy stuff from there.
Companies who create the places in which we live.
And that's a very different dynamic than like somebody who, you know,
I'm buying pants from when, when it's, uh, when it's in many ways, the,
the spaces on which, uh, the,
the public discourse is had,
and in places in which I sort of feel like I live my life.
That's actually a great observation where people, I think,
think to themselves, well, what's the big deal. Like I go on these things and,
you know, they, they reach me with ads,
but you said it in a really profound way. It's like, this is where you live now,
you know, like, this is how you're experiencing the world.
This is how you're developing your point of view.
Your worldviews and your values, and like your relationships. You know,
I have many,
many friends who I know entirely through social media and have never met in the
real world. I started a business that is now like, I, I, you know,
makes millions of dollars a year with a guy who I did not meet.
And for like five years into running the business with him and, uh, not,
not in the real world. I mean, and that, like,
I really do think that, like,
we are going to eventually realize that these companies are more than companies
and in a way they are their own governments.
And that like the board of Facebook and Cheryl, uh,
and, and Mark are like the government of that company.
Like they're the leaders and that we need to, you know,
like there are different ways to exert pressure on them.
And like there's internal ways like their employees and there's advertisers,
which we're seeing now there's actual regulations from the government.
There's also pushes from users and pushers from pushes,
from like the creators who are, you know, really big on the platforms.
We need to start thinking about how we like affect the governance of those
companies, because they govern the spaces in which we live and,
and imagining. And I do this, you know, in the second book,
pretty obviously imagining that these places are, are not companies,
but they are in a way countries is, and they are countries that are, you know,
sort of totalitarian autocracies by capitalist autocracy.
Like presiding over his
2.2 billion subjects say today,
you will see this and you will like it. And it will be good.
Yeah. And, and like the, the algorithms now are extremely sophisticated,
but I think they're nothing like what they're going to be and 10 or 20 years.
And when I talked to it, like well-meaning, uh,
business leaders in Valley who are running these big companies and,
and have a lot of, you know, maybe more influenced than they realize they have.
Um, I kind of want to ask them, like, not just like,
how do you make sure you do this right.
But how do you make sure that once you've consolidated this bunch of power in
one place, the person who takes over after you're gone,
how do you make sure that they do it right?
How do you make sure in like 50 years when, you know,
Facebook looks a lot sort of older and stodgier, and it's sort of like on its,
you know, maybe on its way out,
maybe there are competitors and they're trying everything they can to,
to keep that shareholder value increasing. Like, what does that world look like?
Not just, what does the world now look like?
And they don't really tend to respond. What will that question?
I think it kind of scares them to think 50 years in the future.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know,
every time we have a new episode.